howard beck uh the national nba
columnist at bleach report back here on
the program to discuss it how are you
howard
hey rich what's going on man where do
you what do you think of the derrick
rose what do you think of when you
when you hear the heard that derek rose
dropped 50
last night yeah it's funny because i i
did not have that game on so it was one
of those things where i had
you know twitter was giving the constant
updates that you know just expressing
the uh
uh surprise uh elation everything else
that you saw just kind of coming
uh out of the uh the ether
as people saw this um i think my first
thought is is simply
that you know it's a lesson that we
can't write guys off too
soon and then listen this is not soon
right like there were many many years
where derek rose did not look like
derrick rose anymore and i think
if you concluded as many teams did by
the way
that the best of derrick rose was
already behind him there was
ample evidence to back that up and so to
see a throwback performance like that i
mean i think
you know you you have to to have the
reality check in mind which is that if
he was still
capable of doing all this where was it
during that weird season with the knicks
where was it
during his brief stay with the cavs um
you know what did the utah jazz not see
that they decided to cut him when they
traded for him
uh last what was a january february they
didn't even want him
they did it for you know you know cap
purposes and then immediately waved him
and that's when he ended up going to
minnesota there wasn't a ton of interest
in him and he signed for a minimum deal
and it's a it's a a culmination of a lot
of things but not least of which is that
derek rose didn't look like he was ever
going to be that guy again so to see it
last night
if you're derek rose fan if you love
them with the bulls and and
it's nice to see that um a lot has
happened since then both on and off the
court that we don't necessarily need to
get into in this discussion but
um i understand people being happy to
see that version of rose appear again
we'll see if that's sustainable or if
that was just
you know a a one-night throwback what do
you think was going through his mind
when he was crying
at the end of that performance last
night
i have to believe that that that was
more than anything
just the um the the uh
joy of being that player again you know
when you're the youngest mvp
in nba history which he was back in what
2011
um think that the world is is
you know is that your fingertips at that
point that this is this is just the
beginning
you you know they they went toe to toe
the bulls with
lebron's heat and it looked like they
were going to be the biggest rivals to
to the miami heat during that era and it
didn't happen
and part of it was derrick rose falling
apart and then other guys
physically falling apart and that that
bulls team just crumbled
and derrick rose was just kind of you
know
lost in the wilderness at that point um
you know he was never able to quite get
it back
jimmy butler emerged as as the bigger
star for chicago
and you know i i i you know
the athlete never believes they're
always the last one to believe that
they're done right or that their best
days are behind them that they can't be
the the superstar anymore and everybody
else had
i think understandably decided that
derrick rose wasn't that guy anymore
you got to think that derek rose in his
mind still believed it believed that he
could could get back to that level and i
think to do it last night that the the
tears at the end is probably just that
you know that belief had a a you know
a payoff that that it's still there well
after
after the performance leaked out to here
to los angeles
howard howard back at bleacher report
here on the rich eisenhower lebron
called him a superhero
and we saw the reaction from his
teammates and we also saw on nba twitter
the must follow
on twitter that uh what the players
think of him
uh has this been brewing for a long time
and just uh we
we we didn't hear about the way that
players felt about derrick rose because
of
uh i guess his journey that you've just
mentioned
no i think the players have always been
um
pretty supportive of and and um
just generally felt you know
empathy for for derrick rose um because
of everything he went through physically
because of the knee
surgeries because he like listen
stars appreciate the other stars then
the players always appreciate the elite
talents and so to see a guy
who is still so young in his career have
that taken from him
because of the knee problems um i
you know it look a lot of guys in this
league too it
sort of came up on him right like he's
been around long enough that a lot of
the players in the league
were watching him as junior higher high
school kids so there's a reverence there
and a respect for him and what he had
accomplished and so i think that's where
a lot of that outpouring of support
stems from if this was the nfl and we
would be
completely knee-jerk overreacting after
a big performance like this
uh we would say that derrick rose is the
guy
who's going to glue this team together
as jimmy butler
uh was ripping it apart uh what do you
say about that as we're learning about
jimmy butler apparently coming up with a
six-week plan to get out of minnesota
howard yeah which was immediately
disputed um there's conflicting reports
as we call it
um on on that subject or that
interpretation of jimmy butler's
night off um look i mean i don't think
anybody
disagrees or maybe tom zebudo does but i
think most people believe that
eventually jimmy butler is going to be
somewhere else sooner than later he's
going to get traded
because he's not going to resign and
they can't take the chance of keeping
him having him walk for nothing next
summer
so that's inevitable the other part of
that
you know who leads the team in his
absence is it karl anthony towns
is it derrick rose is it somebody that
they get back in the jimmy butler trade
unlikely
um you know that's the interesting part
but i don't think that
you know anybody in the nba would look
at what derrick rose did last night and
say well there you go you've got your
jimmy butler replacement uh go ahead and
trade him you'll be fine
um you know one game is it does not
erase
uh all of the you know many uh strange
turns
that have gone on with derrick rose over
the last few years again both on and off
the court so i don't think if you're a
franchise you're relying on the idea
that he has somehow
regained his his star powers at this
stage of his career after so many years
of struggling
um it's possible to summon that once in
a while doing it every night in a night
out is what actually separates
the really good players from the
superstars and so
the question is what can he continue to
do with an expanded role and i don't
think we know
howard back bleach report here on the
rich eisen show
uh sum up what you think the first
couple of
weeks of lebron lakers basketball means
man
it's just we were because we're talking
about i
as you know you were the first guest i
believe of uh my wife's
uh podcast that she hosts uh on podcast
won the official lakers podcast howard
so
uh there's a there's so many different
outlets talking about it and i'm
watching every last second of it
and it is just a a bunch of fun
i don't know how fun it is sometimes
with lakers to go through it
what are you what are you thinking about
what the first two weeks
means here i i think we should not draw
any meaning from it rich
i think we should if you're look unless
you're a laker fan
and you're heavily invested in the idea
they're going to be great again
immediately
i i think for the mo for most of us who
are just innocent bystanders who just
like love the game and love
spectacle and good basketball i think
you should just enjoy this
it's been fun they're fun to watch they
like the
they the ball moves their pace is
incredible
i don't know if they can sustain it all
year but um
they're fun to watch javale mcgee looks
like a whole new player he does
lance is doing good things um brandon
ingram the
fight and suspension the side um is
looking pretty good he had some nice
moments last night lebron looks great i
mean
you know if you just watched them for
five minutes you'd think this was a
really good team
i don't think i meant that quite as as
mean-spirited
no i don't know i know what you're
saying i i totally know what you're
saying because lance says you said doing
some good things and then
he'll lead a fast break and try and no
look uh behind the backpack
to lebron
basketball is entertainment as well as
competition and it is
they're entertaining they are fun to
watch they're fun to to read about to
to just observe the personalities but i
think
like seriously the play offensively they
have the potential to be really really
good they've got to figure it out
defensively if they're going to become a
viable playoff team
but um in the meantime i just think
they're incredibly entertaining they're
playing a nice brand of basketball
kuzma's had some nice moments lonzo's
looking good um
and then the rest of it is is what i
would always say it's two weeks in give
them time it's a brand new team
and you know it it takes a while and
they do have some holes by the way i
mean look they don't have enough
uh you know rim protection outside of
javale mcgee
they need more bigs they need more
three-point shooting these are things
that we knew in july
and those things haven't changed so
they're going to have their ups and
downs but it's early
well i mean and uh i saw a tweet today
um
discussing the houston rockets conundrum
at one and five and how
uh hardin and paul haven't really played
together yet and daryl murray responded
to it saying we have no alibi
um and and we hear about that moral
maury has been offering an absurd number
of first-round selections for butler uh
how how
panicked do you think the rocket should
be again knowing the caveat of it's just
two weeks
quickly i want to point out how
incredibly corny daryl was actually
being with that tweet because what
happened was zach lowe tweeted that they
were ugly and so daryl came back with we
have
no alibi i got it now okay i should know
that there's something better
at stake than with daryl moore with him
involved it's even
cheesier than you thought so
but they uh i guess they probably don't
have an album i'll give them an alibi
the alibi is that
uh harden has been hurt and missed a
couple games and chris paul was
suspended a couple of games
and they also lost a couple of key role
guys in the off season with with a
reason
and uh mute and so they're just not the
same team as they were last year and it
is early and they've had some
uh you know little bumps in the road i'm
not sure if it's
reason to panic yet um again i tend at
this point in the season to not
overreact to anybody's
performances but it's concerning you
know when you were a 65-win team in the
team that had the best shot seemingly at
knocking off the warriors last spring
and now
you're you know you're in this kind of
early rut uh i think they'll be much
better than this
i still don't think they're going to be
as good as they were last season
and look struggles or no struggles
daryl mori would be throwing everything
he could at the timberwolves to try to
get
jimmy butler and bryant blues because
that's what daryl does that's that's
always been his mo
he wants the stars he's going to go all
out to get him if he thinks he can do it
without
mortgaging too much of the future those
picks if they're all rockets picks are
going to be pretty low anyway at least
the first couple of them
to be in the low 20s um the back end
could hurt them because you have to
space those picks out every other year
and by the way uh
i i gave the larry f o'brien trophy to
the warriors
uh two days ago um i i i know it's it's
not a real
trophy but i gave it to him anyway um
because you know i think adam silver has
the real one in his possession
tell me tell me how i'm wrong man you
got two guys who threw have thrown down
two different guys have thrown down 50
they've dunked uh they've had the time
to dunk on
fergie and josh dumel you know on social
media they're dunking on everybody
they're shooting over everybody
tell me despite how uh what might be
brewing in the east with the raptors and
bucks to
combat the celtics you never know what
the sixers give me give me something to
hold on to here that i i might be wrong
um i i i'm not sure i can convince you
that you're wrong because i've
you know i myself still believe that the
warriors are far and away the favorites
to win it all again
and you know the caveats have always
been will they be healthy will they be
engaged will they get bored
and right now they don't look bored they
look like they're having a blast why
wouldn't they
but at times that that hasn't been the
case the last couple years and
it's early and they're gonna go through
the dog days of the season where
you know things might get you know
either dull or testy or whatever
so we'll see they're going to be tests
ahead still for the warriors
and then we'll see what it looks like
when they try to incorporate demarcus
cousins is that a net plus
or not um what does he look like when he
gets back
so there's still some mystery in terms
of how this will evolve but if they're
healthy come spring
yeah i don't see any team uh knocking
them off and certainly not in the west
and certainly not with the way the
rockets are struggling
and i didn't think that they would
anyway i think that the interesting
or the intrigue is in the east because i
think the celtics
though they have not been dominant yet
they have the top to bottom talent
and the kind of versatility along their
lineup in terms of the defense and guys
who can switch assignments
and a lot of offensive firepower that
that's a team that could really press
the warriors i think
a warriors celtics finals could go the
distance next spring
but obviously a lot to happen before
then howard appreciate the time
thanks again we'll chat soon let me know
when you're in l.a we would love to have
you here
we'll do rich thanks okay howard back on
on twitter the rich eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience